aux Etats-Unis aussi à l'occasion des 1
an de l’évasion russe on fait de
nouvelles annonces aujourd'hui on va
tout de suite partir à Washington
retrouver Sonia Dridi notre
correspondante Sonia bonsoir les
États-Unis premier soutient de qui a
fait depuis un an ont annoncé une
nouvelle tranche d'aide militaire mais
aussi de nouvelles sanctions contre la
Russie
oui les États-Unis qui se posent en
leader de la coalition occidentale de
soutien à Kiev ont tenu à marquer le
coup pour ce premier anniversaire de la
guerre en Ukraine ils ont annoncé
aujourd'hui de nouvelles sanctions
contre 200 personnes et entreprises des
Russes dans le secteur notamment du
métal des équipements militaires des
semi-conducteurs mais aussi des
sanctions contre des intermédiaires en
Europe en Asie ou encore au Moyen-Orient
à accuser de soutenir l'effort de guerre
russes un peu plus tôt la Maison Blanche
a également annoncée une nouvelle aide
militaire de 2 milliards de dollars Jake
Sullivan qui est le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale de Joe Biden a dit
que l'administration américaine se
demandait en permanence comment apporter
à l'Ukraine les outils nécessaires à sa
victoire on l'a vu des gens en début de
semaine lors de sa visite surprise à
Kiev le président américain annoncé une
aide de 500 millions de dollars depuis
le début du conflit les États-Unis n'ont
cessé de réajuster de réévaluer leur
aide militaire à l'Ukraine parfois sous
la pression de Kiev ou d'autres pays on
a vu par exemple récemment le président
américain autorisé l'envoi de char
Abrahams à l'Ukraine après de nombreux
débats au sein de l'administration
américaine il y a aussi actuellement un
nouveau débat puisque l'Ukraine réclame
des avions de chasse F16 la Maison
Blanche reste très évasive sur le sujet
mais au congrès des élus des deux bords
presse l'administration américaine de
livrer ses avions à l'Ukraine en
coulisse il y a quand même toutefois
beaucoup d'inquiétudes à Washington des
officiels de l'administration confient
que les États-Unis ne vont pas pouvoir
sur le long terme continuer à ce
rythme-là au niveau de l'aide militaire
accordée à l'Ukraine surtout qu'il y a
une baisse de soutien de la population à
ce niveau là et selon le Washington Post
c'est aussi le message que Joe Biden a
fait passer au président
ukrainien lors de sa visite à Kiev cette
semaine merci beaucoup Sonia Dridi en
direct de Washington